actually jenn sacchio probably fit in
perfectly there after all she is a
notorious liar and we have the tape to
prove it take a look
you may have noticed this week that your
gas prices have gone up i want to talk
to you a little bit about why
a lot of it has to do with vladimir
putin
it's broadly known and widely known
peter that there was a broad range of
russian disinformation back in 2020. why
is the administration flying thousands
of migrants from the border to florida
and new york in the middle of the night
uh well i'm not sure that it's in the
middle of the night as individuals come
across the border
and
they are both assessed for whether they
have
any symptoms if they have symptoms they
are the intention is for them to be
quarantined that is our process they're
not intending to stay here for a lengthy
period of time
it won't be there for a period of time
because they're going to put them on an
airplane and fly them to the state of
their choice now whether sake is behind
the podium in the brief in the brief